so when you guys when you guys were
doing uh afterlife were you uh
in a bubble for seven weeks like was
no no no no we just we did our normal
lives
i mean some people were even you know
like with actors that you might only
they might be a guest star or something
they might be on another shoot so
they're testing there as well so wow
it's it's a yeah it's a double jeopardy
i'm thinking
you know people have kids you you can't
tell them no you can't see your kids for
six weeks you know
um so some things are more important
some things are more important than
seeing those little kids
honestly as a director i sometimes
remember that there are other things in
the world that
that matter too like i want to go right
close down close down everything until
i've just finished this and then yeah
but that would be that would be great
though if you're doing you're literally
doing a show
about a guy's former relationship and
how much it meant to him in his real
life and and that's what's pulling at
people's heartstrings and then people
find out that on the set you're like no
this show is way more important than
whoever you've got at home right it's
honestly it consumes you you suddenly
i'll give you an example so years ago
i was in a production meeting and we
were talking about one scene coming up
that was filmed in a graveyard okay
and the location manager said um oh uh
we can um
we can have this we can do this
graveyard but we can only have it till
uh midday because there's a funeral on
and i went oh that won't disturb us
they didn't want
yeah hey if they just shut up they can
be there it's fine
everything's about you everything's
about getting through that getting got
to getting get it mustn't rain you have
plan a b you have plan c you nothing can
stop this juggernaut because one thing
has a knock-on effect and it ruins
everything it throws out the you you've
got sometimes when you've got an actor
for one day to do all
episodes and they haven't got another
day so that
it's a a minefield honestly so that's
why you start thinking like that like
nothing can go wrong no one can be late
so yeah it does it does turn you into
this this crazy sort of narcissist
it's great your work ethic though is
really amazing the fact that you were
able to go out and shoot a special and
write an hour
and write for the show and direct the
show it's it's really crazy your ability
to do that um
are you are you like that good at being
disciplined or does creativity just kind
of hit you and whatever it hits you you
do [ __ ]
honestly it doesn't feel like that it i
i do feel that
every every project overlaps with two or
three it does feel like i'm always
employed but it doesn't feel like i'm
working hard every day and sweating and
you know too much except publicity that
when because um you that crunch is all
into a couple of weeks that's when i
feel stressed when i go i've got
you know 30 interviews today or i've got
a thing tomorrow i've got that but the
actual work i take a year to write it or
six months a year to write it you know
you look at every angle you know um uh
filming all the hard works done we
finish it for
um
so
it doesn't feel like um i'm overworked
when i'm actually doing the work it's
the other stuff
that
that
makes you feel overworked that that's
that's what makes you feel over and uh
it's just not as much fun as creating
you know um
but i i don't feel that i'm uh
i just
i don't know i just i just i think i
seem to be able to put it out there so
there's not many gaps
between my right project you know what i
mean yeah like some people are going
right now i've got a now i've gotta get
another film off the ground and it takes
them three years to get funded or
something um i think that's uh it looks
like i've got a lot out there and when
i'm not when i haven't i've got a
podcast out or something so it just it
just feels like i'm all always around
you know i think that's the that's the
thing but i i don't feel like i work
harder than i don't feel like i work
harder than most people i know if it it
feels like it sort of
comes easy if anything
what was it about this show that you
felt like could lend itself to doing
more seasons right because other shows
you've created like you'll stop after
season two
but this is season three i feel like i
mean based on what i've read there's
more
good feedback about this season even
than the first two so it just feels like
it keeps going yeah it it it feels um it
does feel like it's growing i think it
uh i think that's you know partly the
the beauty of netflix that they they
keep growing
um
i mean people are watching this and then
discovering
derek that they didn't know about before
so
that is the fact that it's always there
social media so people people talk
people gossip globally now so that grows
the reason i thought it could do a third
well one it's not that much longer than
the office and extras and derek it's
only an hour and a half more if you look
at it as a a
in
total minutes
but i think it did have more legs
just because they're more characters
i've i sort of created a little
springfield if you know what i mean
there's lots of
characters that have their own stories
um it's about bigger subjects
you know it is about it you know it's
about
life and death and love and grief and
all those things that
you know it can't really be over
explored um and i love the project and
you know that there is a part of me that
thinks it is
i mean it's mad to stop now
it's 18 episodes that's not even a whole
season on american network it's crazy it
seems crazy to stop it now at its peak
but i think that's what will make it
last in the long run that it is finite
and they can and it's not a traditional
sitcom
when you do you know a sitcom unlike a
film or a book is
that is like you know beginning middle
and end sitcom is all middle now this
wasn't traditionally a sitcom so i did
have to have a beginning middle end so
it does seem like it it lends itself to
being at least
finite and i think that's what i think
that's what will make it last we don't
know but you know i do want people to
watch it in
10 years uh i love season three uh of
afterlife and i realized like the part
that really and you've been doing this
throughout but for some reason it just
hit uh it just hit differently this time
the part that really tickled me
was how
completely like sad to the core the show
is like at its essence it's just such a
sad existence that your character has
and watching this sad man
go in and interview
people for the newspaper i mean those
are my favorite scenes when you talk
about creating a springfield listening
to the woman
talking about self-publishing her 37
books and just your character reacting
like
yeah sure yep yep self-published yeah no
it's passion's important too yeah no
totally like
well
that's the reason i made him a a local
reporter because that was one of the
last things i i came to is because
um i wanted him to have to deal
with banality because it was because it
was so it hurt more and then i made it
that's sort of one of the things that
saved him as well because i think that
that
we underestimate normal
things you have to do saving your life
like he doesn't kill himself initially
because the dog's hungry
so that's a chore and it's a dependence
um and then he has to go to work because
he has to earn enough money to drink or
whatever um and then he has to deal with
people and he
and he suddenly feels spoiled because he
meets people worse off than him
so
in the end all those things that you
just have to do you just have to do
stuff
was this was one of the things that
keeps someone alive did does that make
do you not yeah yeah makes perfect sense
yeah yeah yeah and there's something but
there's something even more
kind of
it speaks to how pathetic
life in general is when you're watching
like this whole thing is going on right
and there's just the the guy sitting
next to him and his whole job is just to
sit there and hold that awful digital
camera
and just at the end hold it up and click
like it just it just really
defines how sort of
mundane and pathetic and dumb the whole
process is
i think that's the thing isn't it if
if you if you if you're not in a good
place and you start looking at your life
it doesn't take many steps for the
average person to go oh my god
i'm worthless the world could do without
me and
they're right but every that's
everyone's like that that's the true of
everyone that we don't matter we don't
we're not as important as bees
if every if every human in the world was
wiped out tomorrow the work the rest of
it would carry on it would be better off
it would be brilliant if you lose bees
we're a desert in about three weeks
so if you start so all you all we are is
experience machines i say it's my
stand-up you know you don't exist for 13
and a half billion years then you have
80 90 years if you're lucky then you die
never to exist again and we're all in
the same boat and it's brilliant i think
life is brilliant because it's finite
you know we're experience machines you
can't even choose who you are you can't
choose where you're born you can't
choose who your parents were you can't
choose your brain that's my that's done
you've got by the time you start
thinking about your personality you've
got it that you've done it yeah that's
it you can't even choose your own
thoughts they come to you they're not
yours we're vessels so if you think of
it like that and you think we're all
going to be dead soon
life's better life is just better and
it's made me think
that i i don't get angry at someone who
you know
cuts me up in the row because i think
we'll both be dead one day i know but
just hopefully them a lot sooner
it suddenly it suddenly seems so
bizarre to worry about a tiny thing when
you think but what will i think about
this in ten years oh
i i think i feel ashamed to worry about
it but it's crazy though you're right
but when you're in the loop in the in
the moment of that negative spiral like
when i'm in that place it's so hard to
see that perspective like like when i'm
like
it's [ __ ] nothing means anything and
it's like i know that's irrational
but it's like it's very hard to pull out
of that in that moment it's like a
chemical thing almost but it's so easy
as well it's like
it's that thing that if you go on a
corner and you bump into someone and you
go oh sorry and they don't say sorry you
said why didn't they say sorry yeah
so it's like
yeah that split second it's i think it's
about justice
i think people want justice and we we
we don't get it you know um some people
think we get just you know if you if you
believe in god then you think that
everything's justice and it'll be but um
you know if you're an atheist like me we
feel that we we're not getting justice
so that's what fiction does i make
everything right in fiction i make
everything i make the bad guys get me so
that that's the beauty of fiction it's
uh you know you're god you're you're you
know you're making things fair and just
yeah your idea of justice or your
version of justice you can work out in
fiction
yeah whatever exactly yeah and and
that's obviously dangerous because
either we we can't that's why we're not
in charge because we can't always get it
right i you know i i i think it's
you think about the you know like i've
had discussions with a death penalty
about the death and someone said yeah
but you know what if your mum was
murdered uh i'd go yeah i'd want i want
to kill them so that's why i shouldn't
be in charge
that's why it shouldn't be an emotive
issue because if we do that you know if
we were
you know people who carry guns they use
them because they've got them and they
they're angry and they that's why you
you know
but it is it is like you're the idea of
of justice everybody thinks about it in
like the most narrow terms like your
life
can be better than the person who cut
you off
in every single way like you have had
every advantage possible but the fact
that they didn't say sorry
means that they were unfair to you and
you're not noticing anything else about
your life that's better than theirs it's
just no
i'm owed
an apology
yeah with that with the jeopardy and
you're right you can be you can be taken
down a road to make your life so much
worse everyone should just walk away
everyone should really to quote the
bible we should all just turn the other
cheek because then we all have a better
life yeah
but you're right in the in the moment
you think well this
this person needs to be punished for
eating too loudly in this restaurant
you're sitting there going like man a
third season of a show that i just
created out of my brain on netflix and
everybody loves it
why the [ __ ] would he not stop chewing i
know i carry i sometimes carry earplugs
with me now someone's annoying me i put
earplugs in and jane goes that's
sociable
[Laughter]
that really drives you nuts right it
really drives you crazy
we're in a cab once me and jane right
and we went past this lovely looking
little restaurant and i went oh that
looks lovely jane went yeah we went
there once um but you we had to leave
because you said some [ __ ] was chewing
wow so it bothers you bad enough that
you'll put an earplug in just so you can
enjoy your meal
honestly i don't know
uh and like if like we had once there
was a waiter there and he kept going
and i kept giving him dirty looks and
jane was going he doesn't know why
you're looking at him i went well he
should know yeah
i told him that's disgusting
and the only one so now he was there and
every time and now i'm not allowed to do
anything i'm not able to go to scene
right so this is how i got through that
so i'm eating the meal and every time i
went i just went [ __ ]
like that
just made myself feel better but
in the most amazing thing that literally
in life
all of your dreams could come true every
goal that you've ever had could be
accomplished you could have the life
that you've always wanted
and nothing will make that scenario
better
no i i just have to i have to avoid it
at all costs
honestly me picking a restaurant
for the is it's
it's it's it's tough it's tough yeah i i
everything anything i think that
anything i've got this phrase there's
always someone who ruins it i can be i i
imagine that i'd be on a desert island
and it'd just be perfect and then
someone would just come and sit too
close to me and just start sniffing
[Laughter]
but why do restaurants do that i find
empty restaurants now right and i'm the
first person that means the first person
there right and then the next two that
come in they put them in the table next
to me i want to go why
what is that is that correct and
atmosphere was it because you don't have
to go so fast that are [ __ ] spread
out first it's crazy
that when they see people so close
together it's it's it's a murderous
offense and it really is just lazy
because they don't want to walk 10 extra
feet to another table that is what it is
that section is closed sir that section
is cl [ __ ] open it makes no sense to
me it's a table no sense to me yeah i
hate it i was in a restaurant when they
did that once right i went for i just
went for a coffee
with a mate
and uh this place was busy and there was
a uh uh a closed section with a little
thing and i went can we sit there to it
never touch the clothes right
so i waited i waited for them to bring
the coffee and then i moved to one of
those tables and they didn't say
anything and i thought that was a real
win
you're right it's a real win you're
right it is a win
that was a great way because they didn't
have to deal with it you know right um
but it's yeah it's little it's little
victories like that isn't it and i think
people
that's what luxury is to me peace and
quiet
if someone said
you know first class on this airplane is
absolutely packed but economy is empty i
choose economy
i would sit in economy there's just no
doubt about it whatever the seats are
with it i it's just all i want is peace
and quiet i would too but i would make
sure everybody in economy knew that i
chose it and left first class
voluntarily
yeah there is that thing yeah there is
that isn't it
yeah they would have to know
well uh season three of afterlife is on
netflix now uh if you haven't seen it
yet check it out everybody loves it and
and i think you guys will too it really
is it's a it's a it's a great show man
it's really really good
thank you very much and i can't wait to
see you guys it's been two years now
isn't it it has yes
are you coming anytime soon nice um
yeah um uh
well i was meant to be there this week
this was meant to be in person uh
but um i i do want to plan a trip i
think it's i think it's over now i think
i think two or three months the the
pandemic would be a distant uh memory
and that it'll all be over we already
stopped restrictions we've even stopped
isolation here in england now we're just
we're just done it's yeah the flu now
it's a cold yeah so uh i hope to come
i'd love to come up by the spring and
maybe i want to start a new show so i
might even do some warm-ups around so
yeah good
great brilliant um well i have a uh a
great um week and i'll i'll see you soon
yeah good talking to you man
congratulations on season three cheers
ma'am all right party see you later